as women we are very much conditioned
by society to attribute our own
self-worth and value to our um purity
from a very young age and i'm just
curious as to how you in your mind kind
of flipped that script from an early age
and instead empowered yourself
to to take advantage of a market an
industry that you knew people were
making money in and not to have your own
um self-worth validated by
by men um
in the way that so many of us like feel
like we are um
you know raised on i get that um and i
get that you know there have been men
that like have tried to for a minute
date me and then realize that that's the
main issue that they're up against
that's what they can't process they
can't accept that lack of purity that i
have that i did flip the script but
not having a great home life growing up
not having money
i just couldn't allow anybody's opinion
to come in the way of me
not having the life i wanted to live so
where did you get your confidence from
um just not giving a [ __ ] about what
other people think because i wanted what
i wanted more than i wanted to care what
they wanted for me
how do you process that amber yeah
about not caring what other people think
um i think as a performer it's very it's
a kind of like an oxymoron in a lot of
ways because
you have to care what people think in
order to give them what they want to see
in order to be successful you are
looking for approval in some capacity
right definitely a stand-up comedian of
course can only do well if the like
likes them right people are laughing
comedy doesn't only it doesn't exist on
its own like dance does or other kinds
of art like comedy is a relationship so
caring what other people think is
important um though there are auteurs
who did whatever they wanted and were
still successful but a lot of times
after they died so
right
right you know what i mean um
i
just
i'm seeing more and more obviously with
only fans and women becoming um
more okay like blurring the lines of
what is moral what is immoral um and
what we can make money on and how you
can still be respected do you believe
now in this day where kim kardashian had
a sex tape and then became you know
successful on her own business ventures
that you can cross
industries because the main um
ideology or justification that you
shouldn't as a woman do
anything in the adult film industry is
that when it's done because not
everybody can take their success that
you did and and and funnel it into
different businesses and make your own
career a lot of women age out and then
want to get hired in other fields and
can't because of one quick google search
and and they're done it's a huge issue
right and it's a huge issue especially
for those who have decided for whatever
reason to get out of the business like
maybe they got into the drug scene what
have you and they're trying to
rehabilitate their lives and then they
can't get a job and then if they do go
and get a job day two somebody's
creeping on them and it becomes a huge
issue and that's why i'm always just
stressing the most important thing that
you can do if you are gonna start and
only fans you cannot dabble if you are
gonna get in the business you cannot
dabble you have to go all in and save as
much money as possible so you aren't
getting denied a job later so you can
buy into businesses and be a silent
partner so you can find your little ways
around to not be dealing with that type
of exposure because you could work with
300 people all takes one person and they
could just email everybody that day
something that was just inappropriate
something from your past that you didn't
meet your co-workers that is an issue
you know i had an inventor a founder of
an app called con connect on my podcast
last week and it made me think he's an
ex-con
and he explained the process of when you
get out very similar right i i see the
universe very similar and how when you
get out of jail they give you this like
you got to go see this person this
person this person you have to work but
nobody wants to hire you because you're
an ex-con especially if you if you're a
felon right exactly can't get a realtor
license all this and i thought to myself
like i wonder if there could ever be
something like that for the adult
industry where there would be businesses
that would understand this is what this
person used to do but a lot of the girls
like i just did a shoot last week in l.a
for my photos for my birthday and i
hired a retired girl from the industry
who's now doing hair and makeup
and i want to help her get that leg up
and doing her new thing there are
careers and people are becoming more
open-minded but it definitely is harder
it's 99 harder to fit in with society
it's harder to live in an apartment
building like it's harder to have
neighbors like everything is all about
what you already did and it feels very
uh double standard of course of course
it's double standard right that like the
same men who are paying for it don't
want it in their workplace right right
they're like fun they're funding the the
industry but um when that they can't
fathom
like they don't want it to hurt the
brand or the image of the company but
them themselves have no problem
partaking so it's right
you know as in miami obviously lots of
girls i know are doing only fans and
making lots of money and i'm you know
thinking i'm just
of course looking at it every now and
then you might have taken a calf pick or
two you got some nice cabinets
but but i i also know that as a comedian
the things i face already are difficult
so how could that possibly be yeah so
what advice do you have not only for
amber but just for girls in general
regarding only fans that's obviously a
big thing right now during the pandemic
how many strippers went online to only
fans how many just normally most moms
yeah exactly how many normal girls that
weren't making money
went on to only fans what advice do you
have for women when it comes to only
fans well first of all i want to give
everyone credit who put food on their
table without taking government
assistance
and for these people who stepped up and
said i'm going to do this because i'm
supporting my family or i'm doing this
there's a huge admiration from me for
saying okay you already knew you could
work from home and all you got to do is
shoot cute pictures you're going to make
some money
good for you because it's legit money
you're getting paid through a platform
where you do transfer the money into
your bank account but you're getting
10.99 there's no shadiness about it so
like there's that
on the other side i have the concern for
people that don't understand what comes
with it when it comes to stalkers creepy
dudes like i'll give you an example i
just read this story the other day
freaked me out a girl that hasn't only
fans lives in new hampshire one of her
fans found out where she lived he broke
into her house he hid in her attic he
lived in her attic for weeks he
duplicated her house keys he shot video
of her sleeping and finally it was her
mother that realized somebody was up
there and he got arrested of course but
before he did he never he'd never hurt
her he's just watching he was just
watching her sleep he tried to tell the
cops that she had a rape fantasy and he
was planning on raping her so now
they're going through all of her profile
to see if she ever used these words
still completely unacceptable i don't
care what kind of fantasy she said
acceptable but right it does concern me
for the backlash that even these moms
might feel you bring up a great point
with the workspace now they maybe they
are going back to their office are
people gonna treat them fairly maybe now
they are dropping their kids back off at
school are the other moms and dads who
only know they're on only fans because
they probably watch their [ __ ] right but
are they going to mistreat them so i
think we're going to see the
psychological aspect like it was all
profit margins during the pandemic now
it's time for us to evaluate the
psychological effects of it
what advice do you have for these only
fans women or women in general that are
getting cash boom 10.99 or even
strippers you know people get i know
you've talked about okay talk about that
will you tell women first and foremost i
ask every young girl to get ahead of her
taxes because i've seen you know in the
past i remember being like i was telling
you i was 25 26 years old and janine who
is like the most beautiful girl in the
industry she did a duo with uh julia ann
and she went to jail for tax evasion
and i was like this is real like this
can happen to somebody i know this
beautiful woman is going to go to jail
so then i learned that when she got out
of jail she still owed that money like
they only cut back into some money right
not little we're talking tons of money
but you know you can you tens of
thousands of dollars tens of thousands
of dollars that you're when you're not
paying your interest rate goes up to 33
a day so every three days you're
tripling which you know so it just added
up added up added up and so the first
thing i talk to any young performer is
taxes like get ahead of it you know at
best at least do quarterlys but most
best thing for you to do is just start a
corp and pay yourself as an employee you
know get this going right right away um
a business manager is a great outlet if
you can find somebody you trust i have
one thank you scott guber shout out um
takes care of everything it allows me to
live off the grid because i don't get
any mail where i live all of my bills go
to his office he is my power of attorney
he takes care of everything for me and
then also i just kind of laid out like
if you save this much money now
you'll have this much money later the
importance of your credit even if you
have money you still have to have great
credit and just
reeling it in because stuff will own you
and like for every outfit i ever bought
and even when i was done with the palin
stuff i sell that stuff to fans
so when i'm when i would wear an outfit
on set there's a website called my sexy
auctions and i know a lot of only fans
models are using it as well because
we're not allowed to sell things on only
fans that's one of their things they
don't want us selling and i get that
credit card processors you know people
chargebacks all these things so as soon
as i would wear an outfit i'd take
pictures of it on set i'd put the thing
up just wore this on set today and i
would sell it the whole thing the shoes
the stockings the whole thing so i would
double or triple the initial investment
that i paid for that lingerie and then i
put it back into the next thing and so
there's so many ways to make money so
there's no reason you can't save
70 of it especially when you're young
what do you need money for you don't
have to have a flashy car you need to
have a nice car just you know go with
the lexus it's a nice car but it's not
too expensive you know you don't eat the
mercedes you know you don't need the
maserati when you're 24. so i really
just start them small and also
understanding the importance of
not accumulating stuff that has value
sell it to your fans immediately make
money off of that um and don't put
anything on credit cards you're not
paying off every single month like
that's just stupid because you make
enough money there's no reason for you
to use a credit card to buy stuff um and
i really just kind of build on being
financially responsible how empowering
it feels for a young woman to know that
she can do what she wants she can take a
month off if she wants to go to a
different country and travel and she has
the money to do that the financial
stability to do that
[Music]